and we're starting talking about live
music because scientists from the
university of manchester have been
studying the band massive attacks latest
tour now they've used the data to come
up with a series of recommendations for
how to reduce the industry's carbon
footprint now the suggestions cover
everything from bands swapping private
jets for public trains to gig and
concert venues using renewable energy
and they think that fans should be
offered incentives to travel to events
by public transport so it's an
interesting issue this isn't it george
monbio but can live music and global
tours ever really be green when there's
so much power needed to to power up the
venues and people need to travel
sometimes all around the world to get to
them
well in principle they could be pretty
good because if you think about it
you've got you know tens of thousands in
some cases even hundreds of thousands of
people coming to hear a handful of
people and it's only really the handful
of people who have to travel long
distances everyone else can come from
the local metropolis and so you could do
it in a really green and sustainable way
unfortunately it's often not done like
that and you know you see the aftermath
of festival sites with just disposable
tents scattered all over the place
massive emissions of people traveling to
them well full kudos to massive attack
for asking the climate scientists to do
an audit of their touring and to come up
with better ways of doing it and i think
what they've created here
is a template that other bands can now
use and it should become a global
standard for concerts yeah i'd be really
interested to see if any bands do get on
the train to get to their own gigs
that'll be an interesting one but julia
the issue of how the audience gets there
is a big one isn't it let's take a look
here at one of the facts that came out
of the report it said the audience
travel makes up the largest proportion
of live music related emissions so
juliet should people think twice about
traveling to gigs because of the impact
on the planet
i think you'd be hard pushed to say to
people you can't go have your fun at a
festival because because of that i think
the words that you use that are so
relevant are incentivized and i think we
just generally as with any sector or
anything we're talking about in terms of
of looking at people's sort of emissions
is the transparency what if they could
have a certification
uh you know each band had some sort of
certification showing how much
uh they had either saved or how what
their carbon emissions were and and they
had a
people could judge it like that and also
as george says you know really with
festivals it's it's about the wake and
all that disposability that's left and
as we know with the pandemic and covid
and the health and safety protocols
that's made it much much worse um so i
would just love to see
more transparency and and certification
marks across across everything whether
it's live music uh in terms of
you know people's emissions
but but it's not just about transparency
is it george monbiot it's about actual
action you've got bands traveling all
around the world with a huge amount of
kit being transported as well i mean
they could just stream one live con
to everybody couldn't they i mean should
we just clamp down on this
i mean i'm not against having live
events i think they're really important
they bring people together um and people
have got to have fun and you know god
knows we've spent enough time sitting
sitting in our own homes having
vicarious fun so
but in principle it could be a pretty
low impact way to do it
you talk about
trucking all that kit around why why are
bands trucking all that kit around why
don't they hire the kit locally and you
know help local businesses by hiring the
kit that they have an offer and as
massive attack point out it's
fundamentally the same kit you know
there's not a big difference between the
kit that you'll truck halfway around the
world and the kit that you'll hire
locally um and private jets absolutely
out you know i've seen i've seen too
many bands talk about all their green
commitments and how we recycle and how
we do this and it turns out that they
travel by private jet it's just
outrageous and and i mean i want to see
all private jets banned simple as that
so absolutely
minimize the emissions as much as
possible but let's not stop
live events because i think they're
really important particularly for young
people okay well let's talk about the
flying aspect george monbiot there
saying juliet we should ban private jets
what about the impact that flying has
this is very much your area i mean a
huge amount of carbon emissions one
flight from london to new york emits one
ton of co2 per passenger and they're
normally around 2500 flights every day
that is a huge amount do we need to do
something about that pretty promptly
absolutely i mean we all know that by
getting on a plane that's going to be
the biggest contribution to our own
personal footprints uh and i you know
only 11 of the world is is actually
flying and those who are suffering and
on the front line of the results of a
climate emergency are definitely not
those flying uh and i think it's really
important you know to remember that
you know the top one percent of the
world the ones who are taking the
private jets i've certainly never been
on a private jet they're responsible for
for double the combined carbon emissions
of the poorest 50 percent so i think
they're the ones we have to look at and
and going back to when i said you know
the transparency and having the
certification imagine if everyone had to
wear you know what their personal
emissions were and i think you know in
terms of aviation
just to put it in context though um
absolutely you know we should be flying
less i'm all for frequent flyer taxes
but if aviation as a sector were a
country it would only be the 20th uh
worst offending of all the countries in
the world so just to put it in context
um and there's
obviously i advocate there's lots of
good that comes from international
travel it's it's just being mindful of
that we need it for wealth distribution
we need it because one in ten people in
the world is employed in tourism it's a
great way of sending money from the
countries and the people who have it to
those who don't okay we'll have a whole
other go on george i can see you're
dying to get in a very quick word before
we move on to the next step i mean as
julia rightly says you know there is
this massive disparity in the amount
that people fly but it really is worth
emphasizing that the great majority of
flights not just on private jets and
ordinary jets are taken by very rich
people often to their second homes often
many times a year we need to tax that
very heavily with frequent flyer taxes
so that those who take a lot of flights
have to pay a lot of money for it and
that hopefully will discourage it to a
considerable extent